i think the russian people have been
very special to me
i and i'm perhaps because of my european
upbringing but i enjoy talking to them i
find them very open very generous
and
they appreciate support they appreciate
people who say
you know i understand why your
government is doing this or this or this
this is i've tried to stay open-minded
and listen to both sides the thing that
i have seen as an american is of course
this american entity towards russia from
the very beginning i grew up in 1940 46
i was born in the 50s it was
it was so anti-russian
they were everywhere they were in our
schools they were in our state
department they were
spying on us they were stealing the
country from us that was the way the
american
right wing not even the right wing i'd
say the republican party pictured the
russians they were
actively engaged in infiltrating america
and changing our thinking yeah and
television shows were based on this it
was very much the j edgar hoover
mentality that communism was even behind
the student protests of the 1960s that
this was the direction in which the fbi
and the cia were thinking
so i grew up with a prejudice
and it took me many years my father was
a republican
and he was a stock broker and he was a
very intelligent man but even he
because he was a world war ii soldier uh
he was a colonel
had fallen under the influence you it
had in order to be successful in
american business in the 1950s you had
to have a very strong
anti-anti-soviet line very strong you
wouldn't get ahead if you expressed any
kind of
let's end this cold war any kind of
activity of that nature you'd be cast
aside as a as a pinko or somebody who
was
not completely on the board with the
american way of doing business which was
capitalism works communism doesn't
and in particular
communism is embodied by the soviet
union
um is the enemy
so
hence
hence yeah that's the way
you were the narrative behind the cold
war
that's correct
and it
basically lasted
i mean you saw the ups and downs of it
uh when reagan came in i was well first
of all we had the crisis of
1962 with a cuban missile crisis and
kennedy proved himself to be a warrior
for peace he resolved that with
khrushchev that was a big moment huge
moment and people don't give him credit
enough for
for really saving us from a war that
could have could have affected all of
mankind but it still didn't
avert
no because the moment he was killed um
honestly there was a lot of we can talk
about that as you know i've made a film
this uh jfk revisited is a documentary
we released uh this year
about
the movie i made in 1991
but
the moment he was killed i would argue
that lyndon johnson went back
immediately to the old way of thinking
the old way of doing business which was
the eisenhower
truman way since we which we which we
had adapted since world war ii that was
an interim
you have to think about it from
roosevelt dies in 45 roosevelt has an
interim of
16 15 years where he
he he has he has more of a democratic
regime more liberal he establishes he
recognizes the soviet union for the
first time
since the revolution and he actually has
a relationship with them he sends
ambassadors who are friendly and
he wants he has a relationship with
stalin et cetera and uh at yalta
and uh uh tehran rather that's where he
had the relationship uh do you think if
jfk lived we would not have a cold war
no absolutely not i and we go into great
depth on that in the film and i urge you
to see it because it goes into all the
issues around the world kennedy was
being very much an anti-imperialist it
turns out and many people just don't
understand that but you have to look at
all his policies in middle east with
nassar you've
had a relationship with sukarno and
indonesia
uh with latin america he made a big
effort with the alliance for progress
and uh when africa above all with
lumumba he was very shocked at his death
and
tried to
defend
the the right the integrity of the
belgian congo with doug hammerjord of
the u.n he made a big effort
unfortunately it didn't work out because
they were dog hammers all was killed and
then kennedy was killed and
congo descended into the chaos of joseph
mubutu's dictatorship
but kennedy was very active in terms of
as an irishman not as an englishman he
was an irishman
i say that because well we'll come back
to that because mr joe biden is an
irishman but it's a different kind of an
irishman they're both catholic irish but
kennedy really made an effort
to
change the imperialist mindset
that it still was very strong in america
and europe and lyndon johnson changed
back to the old policy and we were never
able to really
keep the tank going with the russians
briefly had it with carter
but then
brzezinski came in brzezinski was his
national security adviser he was put
there by rockefeller and brzezinski was
a pole he got revenge from the poland
poland has always been attacking russia
as far as i remember back to another
century i mean the two world wars that
occupied russia and so tragically
entry points were always through poland
and ukraine
uh so uh brzezinski got his revenge and
carter ended up being an enemy of the
soviet union and
creating
as brzezinski took pride in it he
created the atmosphere the trap for the
soviets to go into afghanistan in 79.
that trap was set he says he said in
1978
so
there was never except for brief moments
of periods of teton with the
soviets and i grew up
under that i didn't really know anything
of this
going on because i was
i was learning i was educating myself as
i was going learning movies and trying
to trying to be a dramatist and this and
that so i wasn't thinking about this
then uh when reagan came in i was
worried again because it was it was a
beat of the old beat which was there the
most evil empire i mean it does it goes
on in american history it doesn't end
reagan got a lot of points for that
and of course when uh
when uh gorbachev came in it was
a beautiful moment for the world it was
a great surprise it was probably the
best years of for america from at least
from my point of view in terms of this
relaxation in the mood
1986
to 1991
were great years in terms of ability to
believe once again that there could be a
peace dividend
but the world changed again in 1991 92
there's an internal mechanism who knows
you could blame
you can blame the united states you
could blame russia for
gorbachev was perhaps not the right man
to try to administer that country at
that point he had great visions he was a
man of peace
but it was very difficult to hold
together such a huge empire so vision is
not enough to hold together the soviet
union i think
the details are interesting i followed
up on that a little bit because i was
recently in countries like kazakhstan
talked about
the the the negotiations that were going
on and
the breakup of the soviet union it's
very interesting story because it
involves everything ukraine of course
everything is going on now
some what is it 30 million russians were
left outside of the soviet union when it
collapsed
they had no home anymore they were homes
in other countries such as in ukraine
uh so it's an interesting story and with
repercussions today
kazakhstan
is a per is a good example of keeping a
balance keeping it neutral yeah he
played both sides
and he because uh
yeltsin wanted uh him to join
the the russian confederation in a
certain way where
he'd be supporting against gorbachev
there's a whole inward battle there
uh i think the the ukraine came along
with uh
yeltsin as well as uh
you'd have i'm sorry i don't remember
now but two other two other regions came
with him and uh
that was a block that broke up the uh
the soviet union it was yeltsin's uh
plan to and it wasn't
make the russian federation and they did
you